there's epic
cannon in season five coming really
season five show me what you got morty
oh uh hypothetical grandson we go on
adventures with you live with a version
of our dead daughter oh oh wow you were
not kidding huh
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that doesn't take a one month
hiatus between episodes but probably
needs to the
theories they just keep coming they just
keep coming and they don't stop coming
fed to the rules and i hit the ground
running 90s kids will understand anyway
i would say that i was annoyed with the
show's creators making us wait a whole
month to finally get the conclusion of
season five but the most recent episode
of rick and morty actually gave us
several massive lore dumps to chew on
while we were waiting so as a theorist
can't really complain rick turnell
friendshine of the spotless mort try
saying that one three times fast
actually addresses several things about
the rick and morty canon that have been
open questions since its early seasons
and none is bigger than rick's origin
story and i do mean the origin origin
story for the first time ever we see kid
rick and not just a mini clone of rick
i am talking about the real thing maybe
you can just remember us getting a beer
see that that picture on the wall right
there rick's parents his actual parents
i mean it really shouldn't be that big
of a deal right of course rick sanchez
has parents but then again rick has
always felt like this guy who's just
manifested himself into being using his
science magic so the fact that he has
real biological parents feels like a
much bigger deal than it probably should
not really sure where he got his blue
hair though considering it doesn't match
either of his parents guess it must be
the mailman my man but that was just a
small detail what i want to focus on
today is his more recent history the
pivotal moment of rick's life defining
who he is if you remember way back in
the premiere of season three we were
shown the inside of rick's mind as a
gromflamid agent from the galactic
federation when poking around in there
looking for the secret to
interdimensional travel yes i'd like
very much to visit the memory of you
inventing your portal gun after a lot of
talk about szechuan sauce rick then
takes us to what's become an iconic
scene in the series where we see a
younger rick tinkering in his garage i
used to wear blue pants besides his
different taste in fashion this version
of rick seems more idealistic more
invested in his family and less
committed to the pursuit of knowledge at
all costs when he's offered the
opportunity to discover the secrets to
dimension hopping technology from the
other ricks he declines the offer ah
pass excuse me bro ricks don't pass on
this who do you think you are a
different kind of rick i guess a
different kind of rick is putting it
mildly this version of rick is at
complete odds with the version of rick
that we've come to know over the course
of the series not only does he decline
the proverbial offer to eat from the
tree of knowledge but he actually
decides to give up on science altogether
i just took a long look at myself and i
don't think this science thing is gonna
pay off why don't i get bath and we'll
go out for ice cream that diane is the
last great idea that will ever be had in
this garage this woman diane is by all
intentions rick's partner and beth's
mother and he has every intention of
devoting himself to them until tragedy
strikes
this prompts rick to return to science
and invent the first version of his
portal gun presumably leaving to find
some dimension where his wife and
daughter aren't dead or at least that's
what we're led to believe until rick
reveals that it was all a completely
fabricated origin story created inside
of his own mind to bamboozle the
galactic federation agents that were
trying to mind scan him you can alter
anything you want about a totally
fabricated origin story and so it would
seem that rick managed to pull a fast
one on both the galactic federation as
well as us the audience or did he
because as much as rick might like to
gloat and claim that this scene was
completely fabricated and a product of
his own creative brilliance we know that
this isn't true first it just isn't how
human minds actually work no matter how
brilliant they might be this is
something that i talked about on a
previous film theory but basically new
ideas don't really exist our brains are
constantly remixing everything that we
hear feel smell and taste research has
shown that when we're trying to form a
quote-unquote new idea we're actually
just using an area of the brain used for
associative thinking and just
recombining existing ideas now in most
shows this would just be me using real
world science to overreach for the sake
of evidence but in rick and morty these
sorts of scientific rules actually
matter i turned myself into a pickle
morty i'm pickle rick i mean sometimes
but now the existence and deaths of both
diane and beth seems all but confirmed
first in the season 3 episode the abc's
of beth rick creates a clone of beth
hence the origin of spacebath during the
cloning process rick implants clone beth
with all the original beth's memories
including the memory of being a baby
held by a blonde woman that seems like
the spitting image of the diane that we
saw blown to pieces in rick's fabricated
origin story then again in season four
we had the old man in the seat which
showed rick connecting with someone over
the shared loss of a loved one you need
the same thing i needed rick you need
someone to give you
permission to live in the season five
premiere we have mr nimbus referencing
diane's untimely death if diane were
alive today what would she
establish kinetico backstory with me
notice the phrasing if diane were alive
today this isn't a case of rick merely
being divorced or separated from diane
she dead son and now we know that beth
is too in this latest episode it's all
but confirmed you're one of those creeps
who moves in with abandoned adult beth
rick doesn't deny it instead defending
himself by saying it's more complicated
than that you live with a version of our
dead daughter this little exchange might
actually be one of the most important
lines when it comes to rick and morty
lore now it's worth mentioning that some
people have come to the conclusion that
this line means rick cloned a
replacement for his dead daughter kind
of like space beth in fact that was a
theory put forth in a video by nerdist
we're left reeling and processing the
fact that the beth we thought we knew is
not the original bet however dan harmon
co-creator of the show and one of my
all-time favorite guests on this show
actually went into the comments of that
video to set the record straight saying
that a different version of a dead
daughter could also be referring to a
universe where she doesn't die now he
doesn't outright say that this is the
case and i appreciate a creator who
wants to give the fans freedom to come
up with their own interpretations and
predictions but i mean all the evidence
that we've covered so far doesn't lie in
fact this episode not only confirms beth
and diane's death it shows us what rick
does in the aftermath notice the portal
gun that memory rick uses throughout the
episode it's a crudely hacked together
version of the real portal gun but it's
not just bird person having a bad memory
of what the gun looked like it's really
an early model of the gun one in fact
that we've seen before again in the
fabricated origin story of rick rick
puts it together in his garage after his
loved ones blow up and that's not all
check out rick's haircut in this exact
moment the exact same as the one we see
him with in the garage before his
family's death this immediately connects
memory rick blue pants rick and rick all
as the same person and we see even more
later in the episode we flashed through
a lot of brief moments in rick's history
with bird person including squanchy's
stand-up comedy night notice how rick is
dressed for that occasion blue pants
that is not a detail that the creative
team of the series is gonna overlook and
later in the same episode killing us
won't bring her back it's rick going on
a rampage against versions of himself
the ones responsible for killing his
loved ones and shattering his world so
basically the episode gives us a
timeline of rick sanchez he loses diane
and beth just like we saw other versions
of himself pop into his reality and blow
them up in his rage he's pushed to
discover the portal gun technology and
crudely hacks together a basic device
still in his blue pants and then he
travels the infinite dimensions to purge
his sadness he wanders off into the
universe stealing and selling illegal
substances where he meets bird person
whose vendetta against the galactic
federation gives rick a purpose rick
joins the crew and together they take
down not only the federation but also
the ricks that killed beth and diane
ultimately that revenge winds up hollow
and as sci-fi rick says doesn't bring
his loved ones back so he does what
memory rick describes as creepy and
pathetic he goes to fill the role of
another rick in another dimension one
where that rick abandoned the family so
that way r rick can be with his daughter
again and also mask his brain waves
using a morty like rick said it's more
complicated than that which means and
this is huge guys rick never left his
family in the first place he didn't
abandon beth as a child he didn't run
out on his family in fact in the saddest
and cruelest twist of them all rick
inadvertently killed his family by not
neglecting them remember in the memory
rick's wife and daughter are killed by
the other ricks because he declines the
offer of portal tech he decides to give
up on science and as a result it gets
his family killed and now he's living
with a different version of his family
one where there rick left and he's just
taken the blame so he can spend time
with his family again or at least some
version of that family and see now i
think we start to get to that core
thematic dilemma of the show let's go
back to that crucial line one final time
you're one of those creeps who moves in
with abandoned adult bat we're being
told here that these versions of rick
aren't merely moving back in with bath
they're moving in with abandoned adult
bath because apparently that's the only
kind of adult beth there is for a rick
to move back in with this seems to imply
that throughout the multiverse there are
predominantly two different kinds of
baths those that weren't abandoned by
their father but as a result were killed
in infancy and those that were abandoned
by rick so he can pursue a life of
science and as a result those beths
survive until adulthood of course
there's always a bit of leeway there are
infinite multiverses which means
infinite possibilities but there seems
to be a clear dichotomy here when it
comes to the fate of the various beths
across the multiverse and it all comes
down to a single decision made by a
young blue pants rick in that garage
does he choose family or does he choose
science that adds all sorts of extra
layers of tragedy for rick's backstory
while watching your wife and daughter
killed in front of you is certainly
cruel he's also haunted by the knowledge
that the reason they were killed in
front of him in such dramatic fashion is
because he loved them and chose to put
them first over his pursuit of science
the only universes in which his daughter
survives are the worlds in which he
decides to be a deadbeat dad and abandon
her who knows maybe the reason that he
has so much trouble expressing his love
for his family is because he's racked
with guilt knowing that in an alternate
dimension loving his family is what
killed them this sets up perhaps the
most interesting dilemma of the show
that the whole series from a thematic
level is a battle between family and
greatness meaning and achievement rick
abandons his family and is able to
achieve godhood and sure godhood sounds
great but it ultimately leaves life with
no meaning without other people all the
accomplishments all the power conquering
all of it is empty and hollow nothing
matters this is exactly what bird person
calls him out on in this very episode
the relationship that we i never use
that word is not worth my integrity on
the other hand if rick sides with love
and family he'll grow to resent them for
holding him back from his true potential
this is symbolically represented in the
show by the citadel of rick's killing
the family and it's this dilemma of not
being able to have it all of having to
choose one side or the other that
increasingly seems to be the heart of
this show now the last thing worth
noting is how all of this impacts morty
morty is no stranger to dimension
hopping and finding an entirely new
family he did it once before in the
season one episode rick potion number
nine after cronenberg his entire world
so he knows that his current mom is no
longer his mom but the revelations in
this episode confirm for us that rick
isn't his rick either that is not his
grandpa it'll be interesting to see how
he takes the news when he finds out that
the rick he's known for his entire life
was never actually his will morty be
able to cope with the fact that in his
original dimension morty himself never
existed because of rick's love for his
wife and daughter is it the kind of
thing that would actually draw them
closer or could all the lies over the
years actually push them apart but
whatever the case i'm looking forward to
finding out and that september season
finale cannot come soon enough until
then remember it's all just a theory a
film theory and whew i am exhausted it
is difficult to theorize this heart on
an empty stomach wish i had some
szechuan sauce ooh or maybe some eye
holes or even some strawberry smiggles
nipples
on second thought maybe i'll just stick
to my hellofresh leftovers speaking of
i'd like to extend a big old thank you
to hellofresh for sponsoring today's
episode for those of you who don't know
hellofresh is america's number one meal
kit service delivering fresh
pre-measured ingredients straight to
your door they make it fast and easy for
you to make delicious home-cooked meals
without all the hubbub of going grocery
shopping and i can tell you it is a
service that i actually use in real life
roll the clip you know unless it's hello
fresh delivering stuff for me and i'm
like i'm gonna prepare a nice meal
that's right friends me and hellofresh
go way back it is literally the only
reason i'm able to get a couple of
healthy meals out of my weekly diet
because otherwise i'm just going to fast
food ain't nobody got time for all this
other stuff choosing what i'm going to
eat assembling an ingredients list
cross-checking that ingredients list
with what i already have in my pantry
going to the grocery store getting it
bringing it back measuring it and
prepping it so that way i can finally
start cooking and i've already got so
much already on my plate between running
the channels and taking care of oliver i
am like impromptu existential crisis on
a live stream type of busy at this point
brushing my teeth in the morning is just
like ah this is freedom which is why
hello fresh means so much to me in my
day-to-day life not only do they allow
me to skip the trip to the grocery store
entirely but they also send fast and
easy recipes that can be done in as
little as 20 minutes giving me more time
to traverse deep into the depths of rick
and morty or you know just sleep sleep
is nice sometimes and here's the kicker
the meals are legitimately very good
last week i ordered this creamy lemon
dill salmon recipe that was so good that
even my three-year-old asked for seconds
do you know how hard it is to get a
three-year-old to eat salmon do you
lastly as someone who tries to stay
environmentally conscious their
individual portion sizes and sustainable
packaging actually produce less waste in
pretty much every aspect in fact
according to a study by the university
of michigan hello fresh's carbon
footprint is actually 25 lower than
those created by meals from store-bought
groceries so you can rest easy knowing
that in this case saving time and effort
actually does mean less food wasted and
less plastic in landfills so just win
for planet earth a win for your life and
your schedule a win for your family
there's nothing else to lose click on
the link in the description or go to
hellofresh.com and use the code film
theory 14 f-i-l-m-t-h-e-o-r-y-14
to get 14 free meals from hellofresh
plus free shipping that is 14 free meals
plus free shipping delivered straight to
your door all you got to do is throw it
in a pan and cook my friends don't be
turning down free food here guys coming
fast and easy and fresh to your door
thank you again to hellofresh thank you
guys for supporting the sponsors of this
channel it helps us keep doing what
we're doing here and as always thanks
for watching